summer approaches more people will be at
risk of the Sun damaging Ray's melanoma
is the most serious form of skin cancer
it accounts for just one percent of all
skin cancers but the majority of deaths
more than 87,000 people are expected to
be diagnosed this year nearly 10,000
could die those are more than just
statistics to me I was one of those
cases and you can read about my
surprising melanoma diagnosis in the
June issue of Good Housekeeping early
detection made all the difference in my
dermatologist is dr. Elizabeth Hale a
clinical associate director of
dermatology at New York Langone Medical
Center here in New York dr. thank you
thanks know where we echo that yeah
thank you for your good care it's always
important to have a good doctor but I'm
freckled fair skin what was it that what
we found and and why was it suspicious
to you so we know that you do have
several of the risk factors for melanoma
because you are light-skinned you're
freckled you grew up in Texas with a lot
of sun exposure and you've been admitted
to indoor tanning which directly
increases your chance for melanoma I
hadn't seen you for a little while when
you came in for the skin check I noticed
that a mole on your upper back looked
asymmetric the borders were slightly
irregular the color was starting to look
varied so we did a biopsy and thank
goodness your melanoma was caught as
early as possible stage zero melanoma in
situ thankfully like you mentioned early
detection was so key and that made it
totally curable but had you felt
anything nor or seen anything that made
you think I'm going to go check this out
or you just went for a regular checkup
no just went for a regular checkup and I
think this is part of why I'm trying to
share this story is because as dr.
Harrell will tell you there are no
recommendations about how often you're
supposed to get a skin check but you're
supposed to go every year right we
recommend that every adult gets checked
once a year and then if you have some of
those risk factors we talked about going
even more regularly than that twice a
year and then once you have a history of
melanoma we see you every three months
for two years and then every six months
forever
I wonder oh go ahead I wonder people
realize how serious this is
because that when when Nora and I were
talking this morning just here more
people get this the skin cancer compared
to
smoking and lung cancer from tanning I
was astounded exactly so tanning is
directly carcinogenic and unfortunately
even though skin cancer is the most
common cancer in the United States
people are still getting tan so we know
that exposure to indoor tanning
increases your chances by 75% and having
had sunburns especially during childhood
but five or more sunburns at any point
doubles your risk from skin cancer so
like you mentioned tanning is more
directly related now to skin cancer than
smoking is to lung cancer so if you're
going out in the Sun what do you do yeah
so first of all every day even when you
don't think you're going in the Sun you
should apply a broad-spectrum sunscreen
SPF 30 or higher and if you're going to
be out in the Sun in addition to
sunscreen you try to stay in the shade
when possible you keep a hat sun
protective clothing has gotten very big
I used that myself sunglasses and try to
just avoid peak sunlight I think that
the issue is we still want to embrace
the summer embrace the nice weather we
just want to do it carefully because
skin cancer is so common and it's
largely preventable if we practice good
Sun behavior it's a risk is great
because I am NOT light-skinned or
freckled is it risk is great for people
of color when you're out in the Sun to
get this so we're seeing increases in
all skin types however people with light
skin and some of the risk factors that
Nora have have like 20 times higher risk
than african-americans but we are seeing
bumps and african-americans Latino
Americans people of all skin types so
everybody needs to be careful and
everybody should get checked I told you
this yeah Bob Marley died of melanoma I
didn't have his toe of his tie at age 37
so it shows that anyone can get skin
cancer and that's why you should get
checked because people don't they can't
look at their back and they can't look
at their toes so everybody should get an
annual skin check you don't feel it Yeah
right look thank you again dr. Hale it's
a pleasure to be on or really important
information and you can find a link to
my story in Good Housekeeping on our
website CBS this morning calm